hablemos un poco de las reacciones
químicas así que vamos a notar lo
reacciones reacciones químicas 10 que
estas reacciones químicas tienen mucha
importancia sin las reacciones químicas
simplemente tú y yo no existiríamos en
tu cuerpo en este preciso momento sucede
una gran cantidad de reacciones clínicas
a cada segundo sin las reacciones
químicas no habrá vida y ni siquiera
existiría el universo como lo conocemos
entonces que son las reacciones químicas
bueno es lo que sucede en cualquier
momento que tienes enlaces formándose o
rompiéndose en átomos o moléculas
entonces
a qué nos referimos con reacciones
químicas bueno esta es una de las
reacciones químicas más fundamentales
que existen una vez más si ésta no
ocurriera
simplemente estaríamos en problemas
porque no tendríamos agua pero pensemos
que describe exactamente aquí
tenemos los reactivos así que los voy a
poner con este color estos de aquí son
los re activos
a ti
voz muy bien los cuales pues simplemente
son los que van a reaccionar y luego
tenemos una flecha y de este otro lado
tenemos al producto que bueno visto de
una manera más general
son productos así que le voy a poner
ductos productos muy bien entonces aquí
cuáles son los reactivos bueno pues en
este caso tenemos hidrógeno molecular
que es este de aquí y tenemos oxígeno
molecular y por qué dije hidrógeno
molecular bueno porque el hidrógeno
molecular es el estado en el que
típicamente encontramos el hidrógeno ya
que en lugar de encontrarlo sólo lo
encontramos
formado por dos átomos de hidrógeno como
lo puedes ver aquí tengo uno de ellos y
dos de ellos y para que suceda esta
reacción no sólo necesitas un hidrógeno
molecular o dicho otra manera una
molécula de hidrógeno y una molécula de
oxígeno para que suceda esta reacción
necesitas dos moléculas de hidrógeno
molecular y quiero ser muy claro con
esto este 2 de aquí lo que me va a
representar es que necesitamos 2
leku las de hidrógeno molecular para que
pasen esta reacción así que aquí le voy
a poner que tenemos dos moléculas de
este hidrógeno esto nos da cuatro átomos
de hidrógeno 1 2 3 4 y déjame hacer esto
más claro con mucha atención primero
tenemos dos átomos de hidrógeno
molecular y es por eso que tenemos este
2 al lado de la h como un sub índice
esto lo que me indica es que hay dos
átomos de hidrógeno en esta molécula y
este 2 grande que tenemos de color
blanco lo que nos dice es que vamos a
trabajar con dos moléculas para que esta
reacción suceda que necesitamos dos
moléculas por cada molécula de oxígeno
molecular y una vez más el oxígeno
molecular está conformado por dos átomos
aquí lo ves uno de ellos y el otro de
ellos entonces bajo las condiciones
adecuadas necesitarás un poco de energía
para que esto suceda bajo las
condiciones adecuadas
estas dos van a reaccionar y de hecho el
hidrógeno molecular y el oxígeno
molecular son muy reactivos tanto que se
usan para el combustible de los cohetes
y bueno cuando estas dos reaccionan van
a producir dos moléculas de agua que
veamos justo aquí y observa que no cree
ni destruir ningún átomo tenía aquí 12
átomos de oxígeno y aquí voy a tener uno
y por acá tengo el segundo por lo tanto
aquí siguen los dos y bueno sí ahora
hablamos de los átomos de hidrógeno date
cuenta que tenía 1 2 3 4 y aquí tengo
uno dos tres cuatro átomos de hidrógeno
y de hecho para ser más exactos podemos
poner aquí que lo que necesitamos para
que pase esta reacción es un poco de
energía
un poco de energía
en el día
y luego se va a producir mucha mucha
energía así que la voy a escribir aquí
muy
mucha energía
sí
y bueno una cosa que seguramente debes
de estarte preguntando y yo me lo
pregunte bastante cuando tomé mis clases
de química y aprendí todo esto acerca de
reacciones es cómo es que esto sucede
cómo puede ser que todo esto suceda y yo
me preguntaba es acaso esto algo muy
organizado entonces de alguna manera
estas moléculas saben cómo reaccionar y
la respuesta es no la química es una
cosa
increíblemente desordenada tienes todas
estas cosas moviéndose y tienes energía
y se están moviendo por todo el lugar y
cuando suministran energía se van a
mover cada vez más vigorosamente lo
suficiente para que choquen de la manera
correcta y con ello puedan romper sus
antiguos enlaces y puedan formar estos
nuevos enlaces entonces cada vez que
veas estas reacciones en la biología o
en la química mantén esto en mente todo
se ve claro y organizado pero en un
sistema real todas estas cosas solo se
están moviendo en distintos y alocados
caminos y es por eso que aquí la energía
es algo importante porque entre más
energía de proporciones al sistema más
se moverá y esto va a hacer que las
moléculas interacciones más entre ellas
entre más reactivos pones hay mayor
probabilidad de que al moverse puedan
reaccionar entre sí ahora bien voy a
introducir otra palabra que es muy
importante y que se usa mucho en los
cursos de química aquí podemos ver que
tenemos dos moléculas de agua y estas
dos moléculas de agua que tenemos aquí
las podemos llamar moléculas pero ya que
están hechas por dos o más distintos
elementos también las podemos llamar
compuestos así que esta molécula del
agua es un compuesto
pues
observa que es de hidrógeno molecular no
lo puedes llamar un compuesto y este
oxígeno molecular tampoco lo puedes
llamar un compuesto por supuesto que son
moléculas pero no los podemos llamar
compuestos porque no están hechos de dos
o más distintos elementos y bueno solo
para tener una precisión de cuánta
energía se produce déjenme mostrarles
esta imagen de aquí este es un
transbordador espacial y este gran
tanque que tiene aquí todo esto que
tenemos aquí contiene mucho oxígeno
líquido e hidrógeno y para crear esta
gran gran cantidad de energía que
tenemos justo aquí para crear esta
energía se mezcla el oxígeno y el
hidrógeno y con un poco de energía se
produce una tonelada de energía que hace
que el transbordador que bueno ahora ya
los stand es continuando pero cuando los
hacían necesitaban todo esto para
obtener la velocidad necesaria
ahora veamos que esta reacción
fuertemente va en dirección a formar
agua de hecho puede ir en sentido
contrario pero es muy difícil ir hacia
el otro lado
entonces en general podemos considerar
esta reacción como una reacción
irreversible y yo sé que la palabra
irreversible suena a que no puedes ir
hacia el otro lado pero realmente
significa que es muy poco probable ir
hacia el otro lado
necesitas proveer mucha energía para ir
hacia allá para hacer que esta reacción
vaya hacia el otro lado necesitas hacer
algo que se llama electrólisis proveer
energía etcétera etcétera pero en
general la manera en que esto está
escrito donde la flecha solo está puesta
hacia una dirección y esto de aquí se lo
conoce como una reacción irreversible
y ver si esto implica que es una
reacción irreversible y probablemente te
estás preguntando bueno qué hay de las
reacciones reversibles y por aquí te voy
a mostrar un ejemplo de una reacción
reversible esta que tengo justo aquí y
justo aquí tengo un un guión de
bicarbonato que es este que tengo aquí y
la palabra guión se usa para describir
cualquier molécula o átomo que tiene ya
sea un desequilibrio de electrones o de
protones es decir que tenga una carga
neta entonces esto de aquí lo hace un
guión y justo esto de aquí también va a
ser que éste sea un guión de hidrógeno
entonces estos dos éste y éste ambos
tienen carga uno tiene carga positiva
el otro tiene carga negativa pero ambos
son y
y en esta reacción de aquí tienes un
guión de bicarbonato que se ve algo como
esto este solo mi dibujo de él que va a
resonar con un guión de hidrógeno el
cual bueno si te das cuenta es un átomo
de hidrógeno que perdió su electrón y
por eso muchas personas lo llaman un
protón y esta es una reacción en
equilibrio donde se puede formar ácido
carbónico que es justo lo que tenemos a
la derecha y observa que únicamente lo
que sucede aquí es que este hidrógeno
que tenemos se va a unir a un oxígeno de
estos tres se va a pegar y nos da una
reacción en equilibrio porque es una
reacción que va hacia un lado y hacia el
otro
si provees más reactivos más de estos
que tenemos aquí entonces va a ir hacia
este lado y bueno si vas a tener más
productos entonces vas a ir hacia el
otro lado y de hecho en un ambiente real
en un sistema real constantemente vas de
un lado al otro y distintas reacciones
reversibles pueden entender más
hacia un lado que hacia el otro si tú
provees más cosas de un lado si tú
provees más reactivos es más probable
que vaya hacia la otra dirección porque
será más probable que estas
interacciones o si pones más de este
lado se irá hacia la otra dirección
porque será más fácil que esto reaccione
con sus alrededores o se disocie de
cierta manera y bueno te puedes
preguntar realmente escribir solamente
letras al azar y de hecho el ácido
carbónico es una molécula increíblemente
importante o bien es un compuesto
increíblemente importante porque está
formado por todos o más elementos
recuerdas en los sistemas vivos en el
ambiente e incluso cuando sales y vas a
comer
algo de comida rápida y tomas esas
bebidas carbonatadas éstas tienen ácido
carbónico que se disocian formando así
dióxido de carbono y el dióxido de
carbono es aquello que burbujea bien el
ácido carbónico también es
increíblemente importante en cómo el
cuerpo trata con el exceso de dióxido de
carbono
torrente sanguíneo y el ácido carbónico
también está involucrado en los océanos
tomando el dióxido de carbono de la
atmósfera entonces cuando estudias
química especialmente en el contexto de
biología recuerda que esto no se trata
solo de cosas interesantes que parecen
muy académicas realmente están afectando
tu vida tu cuerpo y tu ambiente